it it definitely it has symbolized the
icon for the arts um it has been a
symbol here on campus ever since i've
been here and i started here when i was
a senior in high school so it has been
here as a beacon of the arts forever and
you know and it's sad to know that klaus
has now passed on and you know this will
be a piece that the university treasures
forever
the statue is just a
wonderful example of um modern art here
in las vegas and i think it's important
that people remember that we have a
class oldenburg
and he's amazing i mean he's placed ice
cream cones on
buildings and lipstick in places i've
actually seen another piece of his in
san francisco and it's um an arrow of
love
pointing into the ground so
just the amount of time and effort it
takes to get these sculptures
created from his brain to what we have
here was phenomenal i mean he brought
this thing all the way across the
country and we have
that documentation at the performing
arts center so we're very lucky to have
this piece and i hope that more people
will come in
remember that this is a class oldenburg
and it's a flashlight
and we just love having it here and we
definitely hope that more people come in
and
see what he was about and take part in
the arts here
and remember that that we here at unlv
have a long-standing performing arts and
artistic direction in general well right
now we're in the middle of student
orientation so they stop
all the time and it becomes the the
photo spot for campus and
it is it is a it is an icon for the
campus so it is it is absolutely
beautiful to have it here and we're very
fortunate to have it